now tonight another example of the media
mobs hate hysteria and outright hoaxes
because
remember last year when border agents
were accused of whipping haitian
migrants down in del rio texas well yet
again facts in reality got in the way of
a far-left narrative because joe biden's
own cbp commissioner admitted today no
agents were carrying whips and no
migrants were attacked watch
opr investigators determined that the
agents involved in the del rio activity
were not carrying whips
opr found no evidence border control
agents involved in this
incident struck any person with their
reigns intentionally or otherwise
but get this despite the agents being
cleared of wrongdoing the biden dhs
reportedly still wants some form of
discipline for you know minor
infractions like using strong language
well ask yourself why does this
administration keep going out of its way
to demonize law enforcement while
continuing to make it harder and harder
for border authorities to simply do
their jobs here now to answer that and
much more texas attorney general ken
paxton uh attorney general
how does this make any sense
now look you'll remember that joe biden
nancy pelosi chuck schumer came out
criticizing about these whips how they
were going to be punished and here we
are almost a year later it's a year to
do this investigation they actually
found just the opposite they did not use
whips then of course because joe biden
and the others suggested punishment they
had to go investigate something else and
and as you said
very vague charges and to me ridiculous
these people have done more to protect
america than joe biden or any of these
senators congressmen
yeah and and here's the president on
national television immediately after
this incident and we see on videotapes
they're not whipping people they're
using the reins
to control their horses
uh but he he convicts them in the court
of public opinion demanding and
promising that they're going to pay for
what they did
so
you know isn't this a case where
you know
god forbid we let the facts and the
evidence get in the way of a good story
yeah there's no doubt this was political
and it's really unfortunate for these
border agents who have given their lives
to to securing our border and defending
americans and here they are being
punished they should be rewarded they
should be taken care of
instead
their their careers may be ruined and
they've been humiliated in front of the
entire american public and i just think
it's really wrong i would expect instead
joe biden and some of these political
leaders should come out and actually
apologize to these guys for what they've
been through
yeah i i agree wholeheartedly ken paxton
thanks for being with us hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else